President Trump is threatening to sue
his former chief strategist Steve Bannon
for criticizing the president and his
family in excerpts from an explosive new
book fire in fury Bannon calls a June
2016 campaign meeting with a Russian
source at Trump Tower treasonous and
unpatriotic he suggests Special Counsel
Robert Miller's investigation into
potential collusion with Russia during
the campaign is all about money
laundering the president hits back in a
statement saying quote Steve Bannon has
nothing to do with me or my presidency
and this morning the digital news site
Axios reports Bannon told friends he
would run for president in two years if
mr. Trump does not Bannon said this
knowing the book would include his
argument the mulher probe could topple
the president Mike Allen co-founder and
executive editor of Axios joins us from
Washington he interviewed Steve Bannon
last week good morning Mike good morning
so lawsuits statements a lot of
back-and-forth between the White House
and Steve Bannon or at least from the
White House how problematic is this book
for the Trump administration well we can
see in their reaction that the fury now
is by the president I'm told that
yesterday in the West Wing people tried
to avoid the president sort of the way
you stay away from your dad when he's
had it he was so angry about this book
and what did he do he called lawyers he
called his outside lawyers and said what
can we do they have sent a
cease-and-desist letter to Steve Bannon
as you mentioned at the top they gave us
a statement saying the legal action
against Steve Bannon is imminent and
Axios is hearing that the president's
lawyers may now go against the author
Michael wolf
but are there tapes of these
conversations Mike there are and that's
going to make it so hard for these
people who have been captured with these
embarrassing and reviewing comments to
now deny them now a lot of these people
thought that they were talking off the
record
but what are they going to do now we
hear that Michael wolf has dozens of
hours of tapes of people from Trump
world talking about him in a book that
in the end gives a very unflattering
portrait
former White House adviser Katie Walsh
who was Reince Priebus is number two at
the Republican National Committee was
quoted in the book as saying working
with the president was like trying to
figure out what a child wants I know
that miss Walsh has denied that to Axios
but there are tapes of Miss Walsh so I
don't know if that particular statement
but yes that we hear that Steve Bannon
Katie Walsh the former deputy chief of
staff are among the people Michael Wolfe
taped in on your air yesterday we saw
the White House saying that there was
very little cooperation with Michael
Wolfe Michael Wolfe had unbelievable
access so we've been talking to him over
many months the White House says that he
was formally cleared in to the White
House less than 20 times but for someone
who's going into private areas of the
White House including the then chief of
staff's office Reince Priebus his office
that's a lot and during those early days
we know how much confusion there was
Michael Wolfe would sit in the White
House lobby and all of you have seen
what the White House Lobby is like
everyone comes and goes through there
and if you're sitting there waiting for
an appointment you can catch up with a
lot of people Michael Wolfe would get
dope from people walking through and
then sometimes they would walk across
the park and meet him if they had I'm so
tell and yet Mike despite all these
banning comments in the book now been
and says last night that he still
supports President Trump and he called
him a great man so what are we to make
of the damage control that that Steve
Danon is doing right now yeah well good
luck convincing the president that this
is divorce this is a severing of the
ties the White House knew that this book
would probably be bad but they had no
idea that Steve Bannon would say the
things that he does but as you mentioned
at the top Steve Bannon has a comeback
plan so since he left the White House
he's been traveling the world traveling
the country building his own name ID
building his own base and Steve has told
friends that if the president doesn't
run so there's no suggestion he would
challenge the president but if the
president doesn't run and there's a big
field of Republicans in 2020 but Steve
Bannon would love to jump into that now
where Steve Bannon
was probably kidding himself was he also
told friends that if the president ran
again Bannon would like to run the
campaign well good luck with that hard
to see Steve been in back in Trump Tower
yeah I think the divorce is final Mike
Allen thank you so much have a great day